I spent a lot of time in the Great
Outdoors
there's the visual Beauty it's it's just
spectacular there's this whole cycle of
life this beautiful touching love and
care but at the other side of it there's
this incredible brutality
Zimbabwe landlocked in southern Africa
tourists travel from all over the globe
to witness an abundance of wild animals
in their natural habitat
those tourists depend on tough
experienced guides to keep them safe
guides like Paul Templer
I grew up at the time the country was
called Rhodesia in the midst of a
vicious Civil War so I served in the
military for a while then I spent some
time gallivanting around the globe and
after years of being away from Africa
being dropped back into nature it was
like this incredible love affair I went
and started an apprenticeship to become
a guide we were amongst lions and
elephant and buffalo and crocodiles and
hippos and snakes and scorpions there
were landmines Rapids uh there was any
number of things that could go horribly
wrong and if you guided long enough they
would
late afternoon March Paul prepares for a
canoe tour down the Majestic Zambezi
River known not only for its wild
Untamed Beauty but also for its many
dangers including crocodiles hippos and
Victoria Falls one of the seven wonders
of the natural world
we were getting ready to do what was
called The Royal drift it's just this
incredible canoe trip you spent about
two hours or so canoeing down the
mighty's mb0 but your end point is just
above Victoria Falls
the group sets off
Paul in a canoe with his clients
followed by two Apprentice tour guides
Evans and Ben his friend and fellow
guide Mack rides alone in a small kayak
to act as safety should any trouble
arise
it was a big guy big strong guy
physically imposing if you're on the
river with him or in the bush with him
which was reassuring he was one of those
guys that you knew wasn't going to let
you down he's pretty solid as we drifted
down the river pot of hippos
came up ahead of us but we were close
enough yet far enough for everyone to to
enjoy the experience and being a guide
and being trained I knew that looking at
where the hippos were and understanding
about hippo Behavior I knew that if I
followed shallow water around the hippos
I'd be absolutely fine I'd be safe and
my gut told me that the safe track was
to go left
and I followed my gut so we went left
[Music]
and I followed the shallow water and
sure enough I made my way around the
hippo to the relative safety of this
narrow channel we just sat there soaking
in all the peace and the Tranquility we
were less than a mile above Victoria
Falls the sun was setting and it was
just that beautiful glow that comes at
dusk
when suddenly there was just
unfortunately I knew that sound all too
well a hippo had hit the back of Evan's
canoe
the mighty hippopotamus is a massive
semi-aquatic mammal native to
sub-Saharan Africa it can weigh over
seven thousand Pounds hippos have tusks
that can grow up to 20 inches long
fantastic swimmers they can stay
underwater up to five minutes hippos are
widely regarded by African Wildlife
professionals as being one of the most
unpredictable large mammal species to
encounter in the bush Dr Camille fridge
is a large herbivore ecologist at the
University of kwazulu-natal in South
Africa and has been studying hippos in
this region for years
although Paul's group is feeling the
full brunt of the hippo strike these
animals don't seek conflict with humans
a lot of human and hippo Wildlife
conflict takes place across Africa but
it's not because hippos are actually
targeting these people they're
herbivores they don't want to kill
people it's just because they're both
sharing the same resources they both
have these super abilities that other
Mega herbivores in Africa don't have
they have this Incredible strength in
their body this incredible ability to
run on land at 18 to 20 miles per hour
they have this amazing ability to swim
where they actually porp Us in the water
they run on the bottom of the ground and
project themselves off the bottom of the
ground and swim like a submarine would
through a river
I turned just in time to see Evan's
flying through the air before he's
flashing to the river and I I noticed
that there was a female hippo in a calf
nearby where Evans had been knocked into
the river the way the current was
flowing he was going to wash into them
and that would not be good so I needed
to get Evan's art I didn't have time to
get my clients out so I turned my canoe
backwards and I backpedaled him towards
Evans I was getting pretty close when I
saw
this wave cruising in towards me
and that's the sign of something large
coming at you underwater and given where
we were at I thought it's either a
really big crocodile or it's a hippo but
I knew that if I slept the river with
the blade of my paddle to make this
large cushions and that was usually
enough noise to to tour whatever was
charging in it
so I slapped the water and sure enough
whatever it was stopped because the wave
dissipated and it just kind of bumped
the canoe up and we shook her on a
little bit
I went back to paddling Evans was he was
family towards my boat
and the last thing we needed was someone
panicky trying to get in a boat so I
needed to calm him down I calmed him
down
position my canoe went over to grab a
hold of him and as our fingers almost
touched water between US just
interrupted
everything just went dark and strangely
quiet
it was important for all of us to get
that break
from an urban lifestyle and being rushed
to being really in nature it's quiet
it's a great place to just get away
relax
and be at peace
the Pacific Northwest of the United
States known for its beautiful Coastline
Lush interior and spectacular mountain
ranges
deep in the Cascade mountain region old
growth forests support a thriving
ecosystem exactly why nature lover and
public servant John chumminack comes
here for a respite from his busy City
Life
I served 16 years on the Bellevue city
council my last two years as the mayor
being a city councilman takes a lot of
time it was harder to get away but it
was important for my family to be in
nature and we found this piece of
property and we built a second home the
properties right next to the Wenatchee
Okanagan National Forest so you're
literally in the forest when you're up
there the whole family liked being there
there were lots of family things to do
my dad really loved to be outdoors he
would always take me on Hikes everywhere
and we'd always go to down to the lake
this area is really gorgeous there's a
ton of Wildlife and you'll just see deer
everywhere I do know that there have
been scarier animals there in the past
like mountain lions cougar and black
bear are in the area but I think we felt
so comfortable and so much at peace
there that you would never think that
something like an attack would happen on
a cool Friday in September John Megan
his wife Lynn and their two dogs head up
to the Hideaway in the Cascades hoping
for a peaceful weekend of rest and
relaxation
[Applause]
pretty normal Friday we hit a good
traffic day it was very much a normal
arrival so I'm working with my mom to
help clean the cabin and change sheets
out make sure that everything's put away
properly and while me and my mom are
doing that my dad goes and takes both of
our dogs on a walk it was getting close
to eight o'clock the sun has set it's
dark out you need a light to really see
I turned on the headlamp got the dogs
kind of straight down we were walking
down the driveway dogs were kind of
spinning at my feet at this point and
having a little trouble with them and I
get to the bottom of the driveway and we
took a few steps out onto the roadway
didn't go very far and that's when I
heard the brush up ahead of me break
it's a very recognizable sound it's the
sound of a large animal going through
brush foreign
the dogs froze it got our attention and
then in a split second this otherworldly
exhale comes
it was loud and what it said to me was I
was in trouble
and then I can hear the pause pounding
on the pavement and I know exactly what
it is that's a black bear
the American black bear the most common
bear in North America with an estimated
300 000 in the United States alone
typically found roaming in the forests
mountains and swamps they can grow up to
650 pounds
Dr Ray Wynn Grant a researcher at UC
Santa Barbara is a large carnivore
ecologist and black bear expert black
bears eat a lot of things but people and
dogs are not any of them but black bears
have the ability to be incredibly deadly
their strength often surprises us as
humans black bears know that they have
the jaws and the paws to make some
serious damage Bears can rip logs to
shreds in seconds they can take car
doors off they can rip garage doors to
Pieces theirs are very very capable of
using their body to destroy we see the
bear come into the light I know
immediately we're in trouble her snout
is down she's running fast and she just
leaps directly into my chest
I didn't play a lot of football but it's
like that perfect tackle and everybody
goes Thrive black bears are really
really fast meaning they can run faster
than humans I mean over 25 miles per
hour so it is impossible for a human to
outrun a black bear
I'm trying to figure out in a sense
what's going on but in a sense I know
exactly what's going on I've been
attacked by a bear
the adrenaline kicks in the survival
Instinct Clicks in
I know I'm in a horrific fight I know
that it's a fight for my life I'm just
thinking about survival
I go down on the roadway I'm stunned I
got up off of the ground and I can hear
the bear a little farther away she
starts coming back at me kind of comes
up tall and tries to grab onto me is
going up high she was scratching at my
face clawing at my face clawing at my
upper body
I can feel that she's biting I can hear
the damage that she's doing to my scalp
and my skull
you can just hear it it's a grinding
sound that you hear in your head
whether or not a black bear has ever
been in an altercation with a human
it definitely instinctually knows that
the head is the vital Point head and
neck is where they're best able to
honestly make a kill and they know that
so this attack to the head and neck area
was a calculated but also instinctually
driven Behavior All I think of is
getting her off of me I'm right-handed
and I think keep her on your left
because you can punch with your right
that's the hardest thing that you can do
to her is punch with your right I punch
I'm trying to hit as hard as I can
pushing as hard as I can to get her off
when a black bear is on top of you
attacking you the advice is to fight
back black bears are usually
unaccustomed to being engaged with in a
fighting posture and so our
understanding is that if you defend
yourself against a black bear it should
Retreat and let you go
I go to the ground
and all of a sudden it's quiet
I don't know where she is
I do know where the dogs are I reach
down
I grab their leashes and I begin to run
back the way I came
the adrenaline is running so high I'm
not feeling anything
that night I didn't feel pain that's
what it is like to be in a fight for
your life you just don't feel it I begin
to go up the driveway and all of a
sudden
she appears again comes across the angle
of the driveway and at this point the
bear jumps over the top of the dogs
and is covering the dogs Instinct kicks
in I grab the leashes and I pull as hard
as I can and they come out I squared off
with her again she's in front of me now
she gets herself as tall as she can
and she hits me on the left side of my
face one thing that they can do is stand
up on their hind legs and use their paws
and claws very independently it allows
them to fight almost like a boxer can
fight so while biting and using those
canine teeth can be very supportive to a
bear's mission to make some damage those
claws are really what they're best able
to maneuver
I can feel the rip I can feel that she
hit me in the eye there's a flash of
light and I know
my left eye is gone
on the Zambezi River in southern Africa
tour guide Paul Templer finds himself
immersed in total darkness and in the
mouth of something
I'm confused and disorientated I don't
know what's going on
there's this like Vice like gripping my
arms up into my side and my head is
jammed in who knows what
and I can feel this incredible pressure
crushing down on my lower back okay
my mind immediately went to a crocodile
I did not want to be attacked by a truck
balance and if I was inside a crocodile
since I had a really big crocodile I was
able to move my one hand and moving my
hand around
to feel the bristles so at least now I
knew where I was I was up to my waist on
the hippo's throat this is the skull of
a full-grown hippo so if you can imagine
this hippo came out the water with his
jaw probably open at least this much at
150 degrees pluck pull out the canoe
Paul's head is probably somewhere in
here and his hips and torso are out here
Paul's a big person he weighs 200 pounds
for him to fit inside the hippo's mouth
it would have had to be a quite a large
hippo I can feel my head is wedged it's
locked as if it's in a vise and my
shoulders are wedged I can feel my legs
whisking around like I'm being thrashed
around
somewhere though I managed to stay calm
and I pushed and pulled wiggled and
nothing nothing I did seem to have any
effect and then it must have been the
position I was lodged down the throat or
something but the hippo loosened its
grip long enough for me to like pull
myself out and Escape
exactly burst to the surface I came face
to face with Evans we just like stared
at each other
well the common advice we would give is
get away from the canoe the hippo's
going to come back and go for the big
object
hippos can be extremely territorial they
may have a tendency to attack some
things that maybe seem foreign in the
habitat but their eyesight is
notoriously kind of not as good as their
their ears and nose are at smelling and
hearing so when the hippo is underwater
it may be difficult to make out exactly
what's around him and therefore he just
attacks anything that startles him or
intrudes on his territory
so I took a few strokes and it seemed
okay but I I got six hands and I turn
and I look back into Evans use of want
and barely staying afloat so I went back
to get a hold of him when
I just felt myself yanked underwater the
moment I was able to get my senses I
looked on and I could see the top of his
snot just below waist level and so I
knew that I was inside the hippo again
as John shelmanack wrestles with the
black bear outside his cabin in the
Cascade Mountains his family inside is
completely unaware
so I'm working with my mom and I noticed
that our two dogs are at the back door
they seemed very very panicked I let the
dogs in and my mom comments how this is
very strange she wonders where my dad is
and then we hear a noise coming from
outside it was someone calling out for
help and she hears the words bear and
then she recognizes The Voice as my
dad's
she's really done a lot of damage at
this point I've lost an eye I'm acting
on Instinct it's in the dark I'm
staggering I'm having trouble continuing
to stand during this I don't know if
it's ever going to end but I think the
only way it may have ended is with me
Dad my mom tells me to grab her phone
and call 9-1-1 and I immediately am
terrified I told the 9-1-1 operator that
I was
our cabin at Lake Wenatchee and that my
dad had been attacked by a bear at that
point she asks me what our address is
being as I am 11 and it's not our
regular home I had absolutely no idea
out in the driveway the former mayor of
Bellevue Washington is running out of
options he digs deep knowing this could
be the last chance to save himself I've
been involved in a lot of things in life
I'm not a person who is prone to
violence but it's Instinct I just don't
like to lose when you're in politics you
like to win every vote
so now all of a sudden she's going for
the kill she got ready to come for one
more and I stepped back and I came up
hard with my knee and I make a good
connection I can hear a crap
I knew that I had done damage I knew
that she felt it I had gotten her
attention and I think that put some
fright in her and now I think she's
frightened of me
underneath the Zambezi River Paul
Templer is once again trapped in the
jaws of a large hippo and fighting for
his life
he would pull me underwater and then
spit me out and then buy it again and
throw me in the air and catch me and
then I'd go underwater and he would bite
rapidly and just see him coming in with
his Jaws wide open and then he like
of course this Direct Hit and so now my
my legs are outside one side of his
mouth and my arms Head and Shoulders
outside the other
and I'm trying to like beat on him and
nothing nothing I do has any effect on
him beyond a shadow of a doubt I know I
can't win this fight I can only survive
it so my strategy just goes to I just
have to stay alive
hippos have these incredible weapons in
their mouths these two canine tusks that
can grow the size of your flexed arm and
then the two large pointed incisors in
the middle because of the massive
strength that it has in its jaws it's
able to push these massive tusks through
pretty much anything that gets in its
mouth it's just amazing strength so the
hippo fit onto my arm and just I watched
it as the bones just like shattered and
broke and his tusks pulled back and I
think the medical term is de-gloved as
the skin just can rip from my arm and I
just remember this feeling of Life
a hippo throws me away again and then
round three as he grabs a hold of me and
decides okay can't break this guy so
we're gonna die for deep water and we're
just gonna sit on the bottom of the
river
[Music]
I I can remember laying there pinned
inside the hippo's mouth it's tusks
boring through my chest my stomach and
all I can see is that light and that
scenery and my blood mingling with the
water
I was talking about wondering am I gonna
bleed to death or am I gonna draw
we lay there for a little bit longer
I remember wondering between the hippo
and I who can hold their breath the
longest I don't know how long we stayed
there
I do know that time passes very slowly
if you're in the jaws of a submerged
hippo and suddenly hippo came to the
surface and lurched through it and spat
me out yet again this time when I broke
surface I looked and there in front of
my nose was the front of Max Little Red
Kayak
grab a hold of the handle on the boat's
nose the hippos right behind me so I'm
busy shouting at him too get his feet up
and get his feet up because he's a big
bloke and he's hanging down in the water
the current is pushing us into the hippo
and I can't backpedal hard enough and he
gets over the top of the kayak and I
managed to then paddle out away from the
hippo while it's still attacking him the
hippo stayed there and with his threat
display with his Jaws wide oh oh oh it's
letting us know that we're not done
we got just offshore from the island but
shallow enough that I could jump out the
canoe and grab him and pull him up onto
the Rock at which point my kayak paddle
floated away once May got me to the Rock
and they just sat there instead of me
with this look of horror and like
disbelief
see Ben I could see Mac
with Evans he's gone mate
it's gone
in the Cascade Mountains of Washington
state John chellman act seems to have
finally stopped the brutal attack of a
black bear
I knew when I made that connection with
the knee I had hurt her in some way she
slowed down after that and there's this
moment of calm bears not attacking I
think that's the point that she decided
to go do something else
and she stopped coming after me
with help from her mother Megan gives
the 911 operator the correct address as
they rush out to try and help John as we
open the side door we see a figure
slowly leaving from the front of the
door the bear literally went up a
retaining wall right by her at that
point my mom instructed me to stay
inside she goes out the side door and
slammed the door shut she came down to
me she says that it looked like my head
was caved in she took off her shirt she
put it over my head I'm hearing the
contact that she has with 9-1-1
please help me and that started the
process of getting an aid unit to me
[Music]
I'm thinking the bear is gone but it's
still there the bear is pacing on the
roadway in front of the cabin just back
and forth kind of working its way closer
it's not typical to see this type of
behavior from black bears usually they
don't attack at all and if so if they
are injured in the process they all make
their own escape to protect themselves I
feel very strongly that there is
something about this home something
about this cabin that was super
important to the black bear it somehow
felt that it needed the resources
available at this property and was
willing to do almost anything to defend
their access to those resources
I'm yelling for her to go back inside
but she stays out there until the
Emergency Medical Group can arrive
after 15 grueling minutes paramedics
arrive on the scene first person out of
the ambulance yells to his partner don't
get stuff out
I don't have to ask if it's bad I know
it's bad I know I'm bleeding and hurt
badly I have a sense of feeling how
clammy and sticky I am especially my
face but even my body and it's hard to
believe but I just did not feel pain
during any of this I'm just thinking get
to the hospital
on the shores of Africa's Zambezi River
tour guide Paul Templer finally reaches
relative safety after repeated attacks
by a hippopotamus
I felt myself starting to panic my radio
my first aid kit my gun were all gone
and then I made the mistake of looking
at myself I was a mess my buddy was
punched so full of holes I could see why
everyone had that dead man walking look
as they would take these little glances
in my direction my left arm from the
elbow up it had been rushed to a pulp
and from the elbow down most of the skin
had been pulled off the bones and the
bones had been crushed I try to move my
arms I couldn't my left foot looked like
someone had tried to beat a whole fruit
with a hammer by the time I've now got
him on the shore he's almost split out
so with no first aid kit all I can do is
try and stop bleeding as much as
possible so I tore
shirt up and tourniquated the arm above
where all the damage is and tunnicate
the foot which had the hole button right
through it fortunately at that point the
the way the body processes extreme
trauma and that kind of situation I
wasn't feeling any pain but as I'm
speaking to Mac Blood starts bubbling
out of my mouth and I know right away
that one of the hippos tus must have
punctured my chest cavity and I know
that's not good and I know that we need
to do something about it quickly
basically his his lungs are collapsing
because the diaphragm's have been
punctured so yeah that pushed things up
a notch then because that is that
certainly becomes very life-threatening
and we didn't really have anything we
could use to to fix that the only thing
I could think of was we had cling wrap
on the on the snacks and I put that over
the holes in his back to try and
get some Integrity back into the into
the chest cavity so I could breathe
again it seemed to work he managed to
the lungs reinflated and he managed to
um to breathe
although they have momentarily escaped
the Rogue hippopotamus their current
Refuge is an isolated strip of land that
no vehicle can reach they are stranded
and running out of time with the sun
setting we couldn't rely on anyone
finding us and when I evaluated our
options we had two canoes left and one
paddle so my plan was to leave Mac with
the clients and to get Ben to paddle me
we would follow the current try and get
past the hippo who was still sitting
there lurking
and the pain was Rising I had gone from
being in the state where there was no
pain to pain was coming in waves and I
kind of felt like I had this moment of
choice it was
should I go or should I stay should I
just close my eyes and drift off and
call it a day or
should I fight my way through this and
stick around and I remember saying to me
I came back please tell my family I'm
sorry and that I love them it was my
great big farewell civil agree
so I slapped him and said no you have to
do that yourself
um shook him around a bit until he woke
up a little and then just said Just hold
on we're just going to get you to the
bank and with that he just kicked our
canoe art into the current
I did think that's the last I'm going to
see of him I thought he was going to die
on the way out
[Music]
time really slowed down there
I could hear the hippo making a thread
sound oh
I could feel the boat getting bumped I
knew beyond a shadow of a doctor if the
hippo knocked the canoe over I I didn't
have anything left in the tank that I
was done
understanding the hippo's continued
pursuit of Paul's canoe requires a
closer look at this specific animal
that stretch of river probably as well
as anyone did until now Paul's previous
encounters with this bowl were just
close calls
he was a very very large Rogue male
about six months prior to that I had
been leading a canoe Safari and he had
actually attacked a boat I was in then
and I'd come face to face with him in
the months that followed there had been
six more attacks each attack had got a
little more intense a little more
intentional a little more vicious with
this hippo having these repeated
instances of attacks on canoes and boats
do you think that this hippo has
actually become comfortable with these
types of scenarios where it actually
knows that it's winning these
interactions and that becomes a
dangerous and potentially Rogue
hippopotamus yeah
Paul's hippo attack may not have been
just a case of the wrong place wrong
hippo and wrong time but possibly the
wrong season as well the Zambezi River
has deep pools perennially where these
hippos can completely submerge
themselves in low flow seasons it may be
more easy to identify hippopods with
their backs exposed out of the water but
in high flow hippos can fully submerge
themselves and they can go completely
unnoticed even by extremely experienced
guides like Paul Evans and Mike Paul's
attack likely took place because nobody
had any idea that this hippo was
actually there underwater it was
completely submerged and unknowingly
Paul LED his group over the top of this
hippo which led to this attack finally
clear of the hippo Paul's Network comes
to the rescue so my team put out a call
that we needed some help and guides from
far and near scrambled and managed to
get to
Mac and the clients on the Rock and it
just so happened that it was medically
rescue team with the former Army Shock
Trauma Specialists working with them on
exercise a few minutes away they came
and were able to stabilize me to the
degree that we could transfer me to the
hospital but because of all my head neck
and spinal injuries extracting Me by air
wasn't an option the decision was made
that we were going to drive in the
closest hospital with a surgeon who
could help me was about six hours away
and because of my head neck and spinal
injuries they couldn't give me any
painkillers they needed to keep me awake
unconscious the check was the paramedic
driving the ambulance was also the guy
who owned the local pizza restaurant and
I knew I was in real trouble when he
told me he'd give me a free pizza if I
lived
Paul makes the long ride to Bulawayo
Hospital arriving eight hours after the
attack they wheeled me into the
operating room I remember lying there
and hearing all these people talking
about how amazing it was I had survived
I was definitely going to lose at least
one or two Limbs and I could feel myself
starting to panic and with the dog walks
in and he introduced himself Dr Ben
little bear I said hey Doc now you're
gonna do what you got to do but what do
you say you take the minimalist approach
huh because his plan given all my
injuries had been to take off both my
arms and the bottom part of one of my
legs tippity when he heard me talk that
way and ask that
he decided okay and he went with the way
more complicated way more risky surgery
but as a result of that conversation I
woke up
having lost just one limp so
the Angels were smiling that night
severely injured after surviving an
attack from a black bear John chelmanak
is rushed to Seattle's Harbor View
Medical Center the only level one Trauma
Center in the state I went into a
emergency surgery I believe that surgery
was 18 hours they're trying to stop the
bleeding get me pieced back together
they're just trying to keep me alive
as doctors work to stabilize John's
condition officers from Washington fish
and wildlife department are dispatched
to locate the offending animal when they
found her she was within a few hundred
yards of the cabin just totally out of
character for any black bear from what I
understand
[Music]
once the authorities came suggest to me
that this really was its home
they had been away from this home for
several weeks which is long enough for a
bear to take up some type of residence
the arrival of John and his family that
evening into that bear's habitat
possibly posed as a threat to the bear
it may have gotten worried that its food
resources or whatever it was dependent
on were no longer going to be available
unless it fought for them whenever there
is a bear attack on a person Washington
fish and wildlife policy is to track and
euthanize the offending animal
that point they did have to euthanize
the bear the game agents came over and
visited
they did say that she would probably
have not made it through the winter the
bear was a bit emaciated she was very
light she was at about 150 pounds and
should have been more than that I'm
probably lucky that she was 150 pounds
because that gave me a chance
to be the winner finding out that she
was only 150 pounds
really makes me think that something was
off either with her body or the
ecosystem and there may have been some
level of desperation that also drove
this Behavior it Still Remains a mystery
at this point but something was very
very atypical about this bear although
doctors were able to save his life the
injuries to John's face head and neck
were extensive it's my face that is just
ripped apart and there's no way you can
hide a face right I looked like hell
as John recovers in the hospital from
the black bear attack that nearly killed
him his primary concern is his daughter
Megan for a good first week
Lynn kept Megan away
I remember my mom warning me that my dad
was going to look very different than
when I last saw him
I remember being extremely nervous
but also really excited to see him
and so I walked over to my dad for
probably 30 seconds
and left I went to the bathroom and
threw up because I was just so
overwhelmed by everything that was
happening around me
18 months in multiple surgeries later
John is fitted with a prosthetic eye and
recovers
a detail from the official investigation
offers a clue to why the bear made its
home there
a bird feeder
we all love to have animals in our
backyard
Birds even squirrels but when you put
the feeders out you don't think of it as
something that will attract an animal
that goes wild
there's a reason they call it wildlife
and when you're in their territory
you're in their territory and you have
to respect that
part of this respect is knowing how to
behave with black bears there are a few
steps that can save your life
day in and day out people are out in
Black Bear Country recreating and having
a safe and wonderful time
but it's important to take the proper
precautions
what do you do if you find yourself face
to face with a black bear first of all
don't make eye contact eye contact to a
bear or any large Predator signals that
you are prey look above its head or
below down at its feet also with a black
bear and a black bear in particular it
is an okay practice to make yourself
look big powerful and aggressive if you
have a jacket on take it off and put it
above your head to make you look
considerably taller speak in a low and
resonant voice yell at it bark at it
just cause a big disturbance make
yourself look crazy and aggressive and
very very threatening almost all of the
time we'll see black bears retreating as
opposed to attacking and if you have
bear spray which you should deploy your
bear spray as you're backing away slowly
don't run
they are amazing magical creatures but
they're also to be feared in a certain
capacity
very blessed
I'm blessed that my family was there to
be able to help me and I get to
experience the rest of Megan's life and
all the things that are coming family is
the driving force it's amazing he was in
pretty High Spirits All Things
Considered
for Halloween that year he had to wear
an eye patch
and so he told every single kid that
came up to our door that he was a pirate
he was definitely still a hero and my
eyes
back in southern Africa Paul Templer
knows he's fortunate
what was miraculous that I was still
alive with that day there were a lot of
just strange and crazy things that were
working in my favor so for example he
put through both my shoulders at one
point and both arms were barely still
attached on the left arm he had torn the
artery but as he had torn the artery it
had Twisted arteries are elastic and as
it sucked back in it had sealed itself
if it hadn't done that I would have died
on the spot in the back of my head there
was a bite if it had gone just a teeny
teeny teeny bit deeper it would have
been done I would have said with my
spine scorecard on hippo attack 38 major
bites and five surgeries later I'm still
here the fact that Paul survived an
attack of that magnitude is partially
because he's just he's a very stubborn
person he should have died the the
damage that was done to me should have
died and
just
stubborn basically decided not to and
hold on
so before my running with that
hippopotamus had often dreamed of
canoeing the Zambezi River from its
source to the Sea so my prosthetist
bought me a kayak paddle that I could
pedal with one arm and we put a team
together we did the fullest descent at
the time took us about three months to
battle just shy of 1600 miles any reason
we didn't complete it was because some
rather nasty Warlords forced us to skip
a stretch of river in Angola but in
Africa at the time there were a lot of
kids stepping on landmines and with all
the publicity I had received and the
attention my story had been given we
used that as the publicity sent to
launch a non-profit that would help
those kids get limbs
foreign
World happens the animals let me bring
clients in on Safari to show them the
blender and the Majesty of the Great
Outdoors
and our part of the bargain is we do
what we can to preserve their
environment to take care of them human
populations in Africa are growing every
year and therefore we're seeing more and
more impacts by people in these natural
places in Africa
in the next few years hippos are
vulnerable to Extinction there are large
mammals so they have very high energy
requirements and require a very intact
natural ecosystem there's changes in
flow patterns where damming Rivers
producing flows and rivers and then also
infringing on HIPAA habitat by Building
Homes and their ecosystem
s are instinctively defensive in their
nature and potentially the aggression
that we're seeing against people is
actually people moving into hippo
habitat and it's not hippos changing
it's actually people changing the
habitat used by hippos we need to give
each other the space we need to give
each other the respect we need to take
care of the environment we need to
figure out a way to cohabitate it
doesn't guarantee that things
are always going to work out the way
that we want to but it sure does give us
a better shot at it
[Music]